ich habe innerhalb von 90 tagen die
modemarke gegründet alles komplett
alleine gemacht und war dann mit den
zwölf minuten
was sie auf den weg für probleme hatte
woher ich meine blanks habe und was
viktor braun momentan vom modemarkt hält
erfahrt ihr in diesem video
ich habe letzte woche ein video gemacht
indem ich auf die komplette entstehung
der marke eingegangen wenn das sollte
definitiv gesehen haben bevor dieses
spiel geschaut bevor wir jetzt gleich
mit viktor braun über mode sprechen gehe
ich erstmal auf die ganzen offenen
fragen ein was wirklich eine menge singt
die zum letzten video und allgemein zu
marke kam meint so ist es realistisch
damit erfolg zu haben ohne vorher eine
mediale reichweite zu haben ist ein
schwieriges thema ich glaube dass der
staat deutlich schwerer fällt die
stückzahlen werden deutlich länger sein
und am anfang geht man wahrscheinlich
erstmal nur seine ganzen freunde mit den
klamotten ausstatten können das ist aber
grundsätzlich möglich ist glaube ich auf
jeden fall und man hat in der
vergangenheit gesehen dass leute gibt
die durch ihre market und mediale
reichweite gewonnen haben also der weg
ist definitiv schwerer und steiniger
aber es ist definitiv möglich wie ist
jetzt im endeffekt der druck und der
gesamte versand abgelaufenen erst mal
kurz zum druck das hat natürlich sehr
gut funktioniert besser als ich sehr
hätte erträumen können nach zwölf
minuten waren sold out das hat mich
extrem gefreut und ich habe damit
gerechnet den folgenden tagen hat das
denn darauf reagiert das hat mich
natürlich sehr gefreut weil das team
vermutlich eine der personen ist bei
denen die meinungen am allerwichtigsten
ist versand per mein ziel war es alles
innerhalb von 24 stunden zu verschicken
das hat nicht funktioniert das leider
auch nicht an mir sondern meine
versandtaschen die ich extra anfertigen
lassen
dadurch habe ich dann im endeffekt nicht
geschafft die sachen innerhalb von 24
stunden zu verschicken sondern ich muss
da eine urin nummer beantragen in
dresden beim zollamt das war ein super
langer prozess und nach zwei tagen habe
ich endlich meine tüten gehabt und
konnte so dafür sorgen dass alle
produkte innerhalb von fünf tagen bei
den kunden angekommen sind zwar
natürlich nicht wie geplant aber ich
glaube fünf werktage sind für den ersten
job immer noch verkraftbar man bringst
du eine neue kollektion raus und wann
kommen die rektoren online
am siebten achten kommen alle retouren
der kollektion das wird wahrscheinlich
relativ wenig sein bis dato haben wir
nur vereinzelte retouren aber die kommen
am 17.8 online alle infos findet ihr
immer über den champion the world'
instagram kommt an der neuen kollektion
habe ich schon angefangen zu arbeiten
ich habe aber schon wieder so große
gedanken dass ich da wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen zeit verbrauchen werde und ich
gehe die sache ein bisschen anders an
als diesesmal und bau vorher machen
passt eps 1
es kommt aber auf jeden fall auch da
alle infos bei instagram was für eine
unternehmensform kann zu empfehlen und
welche unternehmensform benutzten
einzelunternehmer und da läuft alles
drüber also auch als ich angefangen
haben die klamotten zu machen habe ich
einfach bei der stadt angerufen und habe
gesagt dass ich textil und textil
produktion in mein unternehmen mit rein
schreiben will
und so läuft das dann keine ahnung ob
das jetzt für alle leute schlauer ist
aber ich glaube grundsätzlich das mir
sehr günstig unternehmensform und damit
macht man am anfang erstmal nicht falsch
wie sieht dein gewinnen und wie sieht
dein umsatz aus und warum hast du so
einen niedrigen gewinnen bei so einem
einsatz bis ein punkt den justin ja auch
in seiner reaktion angesprochen hat das
war mir auch vorher absolut bewusst dass
es sehr untypisch ist so wenig gewinn zu
machen bei so einem hohen einsatz bei
klamotten oder allgemeinen beiprodukt
niemand verkauft wenn man jetzt auf die
wm es sich daran geht rechnet man immer
mit dem dreifachen preis von dem
einkaufspreis quasi also man kauft mit
t-shirt oder produziert insgesamt ein t
shirt für zehn euro dann verkauft man
das vertreibt meine t shirts haben im
endeffekt er wahrscheinlich so 20 euro
gekostet und ich habe sie für 40
verkauft das macht man für gewöhnlich
nicht dafür gibt es auch eine einfache
erklärung meine stückzahlen sind einfach
niedrig deswegen habe ich schon mal für
die blanks einfach deutlich mehr gezahlt
als man es in anderen dimensionen tut
außerdem wollte ich nicht auf eine reise
und extra angefertigte verpackung
verzichten ich wollte nicht auf politik
beim druck platz richten und ich
brauchte die sachen sehr sehr schnell
weswegen ich fast doppelt so viel
gezahlt habe damit die sachen express
gedruckt werden dass mit dem express ist
sehr dumm und war einer meiner größten
fehler und hat meinen gewinn absolut
gekillt und da mein ansatz von
vornherein jahr war die produkte so
günstig anzusetzen wie es geht habe ich
mich dagegen entschieden die preise zu
erhöhen auch wenn es so überhaupt keinen
wirtschaftlichen sinn gemacht hat also
das projekt hätte man eigentlich so
nicht realisiert wenn man sehr auf
wirtschaftlichkeit geachtet hat außerdem
war es mein allererstes mal und ich
musste so sachen wie etiketten drucker
typen schweißgerät lager regal und
unendlich viele andere
dann kaufen die ich jetzt für die
nächsten drops habe die ich dann eben
nicht mehr kaufen muss das hat mein
gewinnen natürlich auch deutlich
geschmälert was waren die ungefähr in
stückzahlen der pis ist ich hatte zirka
125 t shirts 65 pullover 45 hosen und 40
problem völlig verrückt dass es geklappt
hat und wir so schnell zu sein
es ist nach wie vor keine stückzahl bei
der man bei einer produktion anklopfen
kann und nach eigenen schnitten fragen
kann aber trotz alledem sehr sehr
verrückt dass wir doch so viele pieces
innerhalb von zwölf minuten verkauft
haben und neben fragen wie kannst du mir
was kosten losschicken oder fragen die
ich im ersten video schon ausführlich
beantwortet habe wurde eine frage am
allermeisten gestellt wo habe ich meine
rowling ja das tut mir leid ich werde
euch nicht sagen können wo ich die
sachen hab drucken lassen oder wo ich
sie gekauft haben ich kann nicht aber
einen tipp geben meldet ein kleingewerbe
an und trat textil haben wir produktion
was auch immer ein
nur so bekommt ihr zugang zu den
großhandels webseiten wie irgendwas
bringen alle webseiten die sich
großhandels webseiten betiteln auf denen
man die preise sehen kann und auf denen
man bestellen kann ohne nachzuweisen
dass man wirklich geschäftskunde iss
bringen
rein gar nichts mit dieser information
sollte es euch mit ein bisschen googeln
und ein bisschen köpfchen nicht schwer
fallen die richtige oder wie richtigen
seiten zu großhandel bedeutet eben große
stückzahlen und ein handel zwischen zwei
firmen wenn ihr privatpersonen seit und
einfach mal schauen wollt dann könnt ihr
das vergessen meldet ein kleingewerbe an
das kostet 25 euro oder so und damit
seid ihr schon einen bedeutenden schritt
weiter
bevor wir uns jetzt mit viktor braun
eine der wahrscheinlich versiert ist ein
mode personen in ganz deutschland
treffen und mit ihm sprechen möchte ich
einen kleinen aufruf starten ich suche
dringend nach unterstützung bei der
produktion meiner videos suchen euro
unter land das sich für youtube
begeistert filmen kann schneiden kann
und redaktionelle und
organisationsaufgaben mit mir zusammen
erledigen kann
die person muss bringen über 18 sein
sollte einen führerschein haben sollte
mit kleinen abschneiden und sollte aus
köln und umgebung kommen wenn ihr genau
diese person seit oder jemanden kennt
schreibt mir bei ins tor und dann kommen
wir vielleicht zusammen das ist sehr
großes geplant test startet in den
nächsten wochen wieder und außerdem ein
neues format mit max was wirklich
geisteskrank wird jetzt aber zum
gespräch mit viktor braun bei dem ich
alle fragen mitgebracht habe die e-mail
bei ins tor gestellt habt wenn ihr das
nächste mal die der fragerunde nicht
verpassen wollte check den linken
da kommt ihr auf meinen dienstag erstmal
danke dass wir das hier alles machen
können dass sie die zeit genommen hast
ja größte dankeschön für die einladung
wendig irgend jemand der sich für mode
interessiert in deutschland noch nicht
kennen sollte kannst du kurz mal sagen
wer du bist was du so machst mein name
ist viktor braun ich bin so ein bisschen
auf instagram unterwegs hat mich auch
vor knapp drei jahren selbstständig
gemacht mit meiner eigenen marke mit dem
instagram business und wie gesagt mein
kanal dreht sich rund um mode und ein
bisschen lifestyle würde ich jetzt mal
behauptet thema mode ist in den letzten
jahren bestimmt auch mit einfluss von
dir und anderen konsorten in deutschland
ist durch die decke gegangen so wie hast
du die entwicklung wahrgenommen
also im großen und ganzen sind natürlich
sehr positiv also ich freue mich darüber
weil ich verfolge immer so den ansatz so
lang so lange das für die ganze szene
irgendwie cool ist dann freut mich dass
ich schätze mal wir wachsen wir wachsen
alle da zusammen und auf jeden fall
spielt diese positive entwicklung da
auch für alle gut in die karten
welche positiven aber auch negativen
seiten bringt sich mit wenn sich
plötzlich förmlich jeder irgendwie für
das thema interessiert also ich sag
jetzt mal positiv ist auf jeden fall
dass natürlich die aufmerksamkeit da
stetig wächst also irgendwie es wird
immer mehr auf undercover brands
geachtet dass spielt mir dann natürlich
auch persönlich in die karten man sieht
irgendwie irgendwie neue
neue designs neue styles durch diese
ganze entwicklung das natürlich auch
mehr angebot gibt die variation größer
negativ wie ich das auch eingangs schon
erwähnt hat so lang so lange das jetzt
für mich kein nachteil hat warum sollte
ich warum soll ich dann irgendwas
negativ da beugen aber ich sage jetzt
mal persönlich für mich ist ich werde
natürlich tagtäglich von von jungen
design dann sag ich mal so auf instagram
kontaktiert nach tipps gefragt und ich
sage einfach mal so da muss jeder so
seinen perfekten mittelweg finden um
sich da vielleicht auch selbstständig zu
machen mit seiner marke erfolgen weil
irgendwie so dieses standard rezept gibt
es da aus meiner sicht nicht okay wenn
ich selber in einem thema super reagiert
bin dann fällt mir häufig schwer
mitanzusehen wenn super viele leute
irgendwelche startup gründen oder mit
der 1 einsteigen und es vielleicht nicht
auf dem level machen wo man wo man sich
selber bewegt wenn man jahrelang
erfahrung in irgendeinem thema ist es
bei dir und mode für dich auch manchmal
schwer mit anzusehen wenn so super viele
leute die man eigentlich auch nicht in
das thema ein kategorisiert hatte
irgendwie da da rein starten
ja natürlich also das ist ja immer so
eine sache man man wörtern schnell in
eine schublade mit leuten gesteckt wo
man sich auch selbst vielleicht gar
nicht sieht also leute die jetzt nicht
nicht ganz tief in der materie drin sind
die die scherben das dann alles über
einen kamm und dann muss man sich um so
mehr beweisen um vielleicht auch zu
zeigen dass man halt nicht mit denen in
einen topf geworfen werden kann
das ist natürlich so eine schattenseite
davon aber ich denke mal dass mir das
mit der zeit immer besser gelungen ist
und irgendwann trennt sich ja immer die
berühmte spreu vom weizen
du führst ja selber wie du schon gesagt
hast seit drei jahren nur modemarke
kannst du kurz erläutern wie es
angefangen hat wie du dazu gekommen
wissen ja ja das ganze hatte erstmal so
gestartet das ich modedesign in
düsseldorf studiert habe also das heißt
ich habe da schon mal einen direkten
bezug dazu und irgendwann kam dann der
kontakt zu das sind sollte ja
wahrscheinlich jeden der sich in
deutschland so ein bisschen mit mode
auseinandersetzen begriff sein
da konnte ich dann am anfang so ein
bisschen bei somit wird nicht dass ich
da irgendwie leitende rolle übernommen
hätte aber man hat sich natürlich
ausgetauschten und ich fand es auf jeden
fall gut dass meine meinung der wert
geschätzt wurde falls kam dann natürlich
irgendwann die idee dass wenn ich das
ganze schon studiert habe und im thema
drin bin dass ich mich dann auch
selbstständig machen kann habe da
anfangs dann auch tatkräftige
unterstützung von justin erhalten
irgendwann sind wir zu dem punkt
gekommen dass das wir gesagt haben okay
wir trennen das so ein bisschen weil es
ist ja weder positiv für mich wenn meine
marke zu sehr mit ihm in kontakt steht
noch positiv für ihn wenn er da immer
mit eingespannt ist und sich irgendwie
verpflichtet fühlten
da bin ich ihm auf jeden fall für die
für den eingangs pusch sehr sehr dankbar
und ja irgendwann habe ich dann halt
immer mehr so mein ding verfolgten ich
würde behaupten dass vor allem so im
letzten jahr dann immer mehr so meine
handschrift durchgekommen ist und weil
ja freut mich diese positive entwicklung
auf
wer gibt es allgemein also jetzt auch
mit dem video was sich letzte woche
hochgeladen habe waren meine die ems so
voll wie noch nie weil das thema einfach
unfassbar riesig ist von leuten die
gerne auch irgendwas starten wollen
würden
gibt es irgendein typ der den leuten
kopfschmerzen geld und zeit erspart denn
du schmerzlich über die zeit lernen
mussten ja das ist wie ich das eben auch
schon erwähnt habe immer schwer weil es
gibt leute die haben beispielsweise gute
designs die haben aber irgendwie keine
möglichkeit sich zu vermarkten also ist
ja auch immer so
es bringt ihr das beste design meistens
nichts wenn niemand davon mitbekommen
also von daher muss irgendwie jeder für
sich zu den perfekten weg finden weil es
ist schwer irgendwie jede jede
individuelle position wo jemand gerade
mit seiner marke steht irgendwie zu
bewerten so als außenstehender was ich
gemerkt habe was auf jeden fall wichtig
ist ist kontinuität also man muss am
ball bleiben und organisationen das ist
auch auf jeden fall so ein thema man
muss dass man muss das alles
strukturiert durchgehend sich einen
genauen plan machen okay geht die ganze
rechnung so auf wie ich mir das
vorstelle
natürlich gehört beim oder auch immer
ein stück weit bauchgefühl dazu aber ich
verfolge auf jeden fall so den ansatz
wenn das alles strukturiert und
durchgeplant ist dann hat man da auf
jeden fall schon mal die halbe miete
da irgendwie erfolg mit seiner modemarke
zu haben die clips irgendeine arbeit
faktor den du vielleicht am anfang
extrem unterschätzt hast oder der
allgemeinen beim gründen oder beim
durchziehen von der kollektion irgendwie
häufig unterschätzt wird
also mehr wird jetzt spontan auf jeden
fall die produktion einfallen also ich
leite da die produktion selbst dass ich
mich da wirklich mit schnitten und den
produzenten auseinandersetze und da darf
man auf jeden fall nicht nicht darauf
vertrauen dass alles was man sich so im
kopf vorstellt dass es auch beim anderen
so ankommen in dem fall den produzenten
als er ist auf jeden fall etwas was mir
schon viel kopfzerbrechen machte da muss
man wie gesagt auch diese dieses
durchhaltevermögen zeigen weil das ist
wirklich ein langer weg bis man dann so
die perfekte produkte irgendwie findet
bis man dann das alles so umsetzen kann
wie man sich das auch vorstellen da
prasseln viele sachen auf sich ein und
ihr besser organisiert ist desto
leichter fällt es dir dann auch die
kleinen problemchen sie war überall zu
lösen
keine frage die die ich unendlich oft
gestellt bekommen haben wie kommen meine
preise zustande wie kalkuliert man
preisen im modebereich also ich würde
das jetzt auf zwei verschiedene bereiche
ja unterteilen also man hat einmal
natürlich eine generelle preisstrategie
was einfach ein betriebswirtschaftliches
thema ist also das heißt du musst
schauen wo willst du dich mit deiner
marke positionieren wie sich das
natürlich jeder denkt an die wenigsten t
shirts von beispielsweise philipp plein
sind jetzt 1300 euro wert das ist im
ersten schritt erst mal eine
preisstrategie die man verfolgt wenn man
im hochpreissegment ansetzen oder
vielleicht in ein bisschen niedrigeren
das spielt natürlich auf der einen seite
eine rolle aber auf der anderen seite
auch der stadt liegen die
produktionskosten dann hast du kosten
für die designs die musst du ja auch mit
einkalkulieren
das heißt wenn ein t shirt jetzt in der
produktion ich sage einfach mal 15 euro
kostet heißt ja nicht dass es dass du es
dann für 20 euro verkaufen kann sondern
mit mit den kosten müssen dann noch die
kosten für für diese 1 gedeckt werden
für deine fotoshootings allein für die
zeit also ich hab da ein gutes beispiel
meine trek fans die ich bei mir release
habe zusammen natürlich mit der
passenden track jacke
die haben wir als erstes sample im mai
2009 10 bekommen und letztendlich ist
die zum ja ich glaube januar 2020
rausgekommen also diese trek fans war
wirklich ein krampf ein krampf zu
produzieren und das spielt natürlich
dann bei der kalkulation alles eine
rolle weil es wird sich dann für das für
das unternehmen nicht lohnen wenn ich
irgendwie ein dreiviertel jahr an einer
trance sitze die dann für fünf euro über
produktions preis zu verkaufen wie
gesagt das sind alles faktoren die bei
der preiskalkulation auf jeden fall mit
1 spielen dann gibt es natürlich noch so
generelle faktoren also beispielsweise
wenn man jetzt vom vom
retail ausgeht also sagen ja ich bin als
einkäufer unterwegs für eine für eine
boutique und kauft dann kauft dann
beispielsweise oft weit 1
da gibt es dann festgelegte faktoren ich
weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt hier nennen
darf aber auf jeden fall da gibt es
einen festgelegten faktor der einfach
darauf multipliziert wird um halt wie
gesagt schon diese diese ganzen
anfallenden kosten die ich eben schon
erwähnt habe zu decken
du hast gerade schon erwähnt dass die
trackpads in krampfer und irgendwie ein
dreiviertel jahr daran gearbeitet hast
kannst du groß sagen wie lange man wie
lange die grundsätzlich zu einer
kollektion arbeitest du von der ersten
idee bis das sie dann wirklich
irgendwann online kommt ja also oft noch
mal kurz auf die trends sprechen zu
kommen wie gesagt haben wir das erste
sample im mai bekommen also ich würde
sogar fast sagen dass wir dann knappes
jahr daran gearbeitet haben was was
wahrscheinlich in der rot kultur sollte
ich jetzt mal gang und gäbe ist aber
jetzt für kleinere marken die wirklich
schnell um demand irgendwie produzieren
wollen da ist das schon eine relativ
lange zeitspanne das ist das ist
unterschiedlich also manchmal
manchmal hat man direkten schnitt der
der irgendwie so gut ist dass man sagt
okay das ist auf jeden fall so etwas
worauf man aufbauen kann
manchmal ist es dann aber auch wie bei
den track pence dass man dann wirklich
ein jahr dran sind also das
unterschiedlich aber ich würde mal sagen
ein halbes jahr ist so ein guter
mittelwert wirklich von der ersten idee
bis dann zu release okay und ich sag bei
jeder frage die ich die stelle das ist
eine der häufig gestellten fragen da
aber es kommen eben viele fragen aus der
community
danach befragt und das war mit abstand
die die meistgestellte frage wie findet
man produzenten wie findet man am anfang
großhändler wie stellt man diesen
kontakt her
ja die frage kriege ich tatsächlich auch
in den eben besagten die ems aufgestellt
also ich muss sagen wenn du kontakt ist
das alles ist das alles halb so wild
dann findest du ein produktion und wenn
du dann einmal da drin bist findest du
dann auch über kontakte weil natürlich
leute werden auf dich aufmerksam auch
produzenten aus dem ausland
dann ist das alles kein problem aber ich
könnte ja ehrlich gesagt war ich noch
nie in dieser position war dass ich an
einem punkt stand und von null anfangen
ich hatte halt immer relativ gute
kontakte so in die in die modebranche
von daher ist das wirklich so eine
antwort wo ich jetzt keine
pauschallösung drauf habe man kann
produktion einfach anfragen dass ist
kein problem da gibt es gibt es auch
beispielsweise aus dem asiatischen raum
was ich jetzt beispielsweise für meine
produktion nicht bevorzugen würde da
gibt es verschiedene plattformen die als
sammelbecken für produktionen
wie beispielsweise ich produziere in der
türkei und dass das kommt dann wirklich
über kontakte also dass es schwer und
ich weiß dass das auch für für junge
start up brands irgendwie im hindernis
darstellt aber da kann man wirklich
außer mit guten kontakten fast nicht
viel machen
ok also lohnt sich vielleicht für leute
die staaten wollen sich vielleicht mit
leuten zusammen zu tun oder dort nichts
zu suchen die in die mehr erfahrung
haben und der drittschnellsten thema
also wie gesagt man darf das ganze wie
ich das ja auch eben erwähnt habe
wirklich nicht unterschätzen dass man zu
einer produktion hingeht und irgendwie
zwei monate später sein fertiges t shirt
hat das ist wirklich ein langer prozess
und je besser da der kontakt ist desto
besser ist natürlich auch die
zusammenarbeit also das heißt sucht euch
sucht euch jemanden der der erfahrung
hat der vielleicht auch schon kontakte
mitbringt in die modebranche
und wie gesagt ich denke mal so die die
eingängigen länder für produktionen wie
jetzt türkei portugal
die sind ja den leuten meistens auch
bekannt aber dann kontakt herzustellen
sucht euch da am besten und wie jemanden
der da kontakt hat und dann wird das
wahrscheinlich auch klappen spitze
vielen vielen dank das ist schon sehr
weitergeholfen gerne und vielleicht
läuft man sich ja irgendwann beim
nächsten projekt noch
ich gehe von 1 danke dir danke habe ich
will noch so